Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm here in the woods of
Alaska now I'm going to be building the
ultimate bunk bed Bushcraft shelter my
five-year-old son Jacob's gonna be
joining us it's going to be a great time
we're gonna eat good food and you guys
are gonna enjoy this video
[Music]
thank you
that's a footprint of a snowshoe hair
right there those are Snowshoe hair
poops and sure enough there's a rabbit
right over there as long as I pretend
like I can't see him he is just gonna
sit right there
there he is
just stopped to look back at me see if
I'm chasing him if you ever scare up a
rabbit just be cool and they'll usually
stop right before they get out of sight
to look back at you
yeah Deadwood for our shelter and for a
fire
I think this looks like a pretty good
spot right here
foreign
between these three dead trees but I'm
going to need to chop down at least 12
15 dead trees
I need a little snack break
because I got a very Alaskan lunch here
okay if you haven't spent a lot of time
in the Alaska Bush you might not be
familiar with pilot bread it's a shelf
stable cracker kind of like a Saltine
with less salt and it's one of the four
basic food groups in the bush here in
Alaska now pilot bread is a little bit
dry so you need something to wash it
down with and for that I like powdered
Tang
and if you go out in the bush and
someone offers you orange juice and
bread there's a good chance you're gonna
get this
got some smoked wild caught sockeye
salmon to go with it
um
all right got a good pile of trees going
here I need to take all the limbs off
them to do that I'm going to use a
Japanese NATA this is like a hatchet
with a chisel Edge
oh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I've only been here for three hours and
the sun's already steady oh it gets dark
so quick up here
all right guys here's my bag of lamps
about five pounds of just lights we have
18 hours of Darkness here so you got to
bring a lot of lights and a lot of
batteries
and this right here is my box of
batteries so I've got 16 GoPro batteries
and a backup battery for my cell phone
and for my GPS that weighs another five
pounds so between camera batteries and
camera lights I've got about 10 pounds
of gear I bring with me at a minimum on
every one of these trips
foreign
I'm sure I'll find those in the spring
all right
well I didn't get as much done as I was
hoping but the sun has sat and I'm
running on Twilight so I need to hurry
up and get some firewood and gather up
everything around the camp because it's
going to get really dark real quick
I brought along a couple Caribou hides
all right
the hairs of a caribou are Hollow so
they make really good insulators
all right I'm getting hungry I need to
cook some dinner
oh that dry dead Pine goes up like
gasoline
oh the temperature's dropped I'm gonna
bundle myself up a little bit
oh
foreign
you know cold tank is okay but when you
heat it up it's like wassail or spiced
oranges it's actually really good
all right guys it's time for dinner and
I'm gonna be making something special
I'm roasting lamb shank oh I love lamb
got a touch of olive oil here just want
it oily so that all the herbs will stick
to it
we're gonna set it over this fire and
just sear the outside
oh yeah nice sear on that
now we're gonna roast it Slow and Low
I'm just gonna go ahead and add some
rosemary thyme and parsley to the roast
thank you
oh my goodness this smells amazing and
it sounds amazing
I don't know what it is about shelling
peanuts but they taste so much better
when you shell them yourself
I think it's a metaphor for life you
just enjoy things a lot more when you
have to work for them
all right got a little Indian butter
curry and some instant rice to go with
my lamb here we're gonna start boiling
that up
[Applause]
oh
my goodness
that is so beautiful
I also brought along a couple pieces of
naan too because you know why not
foreign
there we go guys roasted lamb shank
butter curry and naan that is oh it
smells amazing all right we're gonna try
out this lamb shank
that is so good I don't need lamb enough
oh just salt and Pepper's so good
uh Curry's good too
oh I am stuffed
all right all I need to do some dishes
it's time to get ready for bed
I was getting into bed and I knocked my
pillow Into the Fire and I jumped down
and grabbed it but the damage was done
now it's got a little hole in it I've
got a little stuff sack my tarp came in
now I'm gonna put my down jacket inside
and we're going to do a little DIY
pillow
ah there we go not too bad of a solution
gotta be careful I want to make sure I
don't drop anything else in the fire
including myself luckily I don't roll
around much I think I should be okay I'm
gonna put up this camera I'm gonna see
you guys in the morning
oh good morning oh man I slept really
well last night
I was so warm with this bag when the
fire was still going it was heating the
platform from underneath and it would
just be this nice gentle warming feeling
coming up through the mat but even with
the fire out I'm still a lot warmer than
sleeping on the ground I mean the ground
just sucks the heat out of you
being off the ground makes a big
difference
but I think it's time for me to get up
and build the fire and make some
breakfast
oh
boots are nice and Frozen
oh I feel like ski boots
[Music]
it's a maple syrup
all right it is hard to beat blueberry
pancakes with maple syrup
all right time for seconds here
oh
when I was a kid me and my family would
go camping here in Alaska and we would
go berry picking and pick wild
blueberries and Mom would make blueberry
pancakes every morning this brings back
a lot of fun memories
all right I think it's time to start
cleaning this party up
thank you
Hey Jake you doing good yeah I'm such
Western oh
yeah
you good yes
hey Jacobs give me a high five I'm
impressed you snow shoot a long way bud
yeah
you didn't rest that much should we
started getting cam set up yeah
ready
here go like that
this one's heavy but
I get all that snow off our bed all
right guys this is me and Jacob shelter
for the night I want to finish it up I
want to go ahead and put some walls on
it and get it all battened down because
it's a lot windier today so we're gonna
be a lot more exposed to the element
well finding dead trees a cut won't be a
problem about nine out of 10 trees here
are dead already in the summertime this
place is a massive forest fire risk so
thinning out some of these dead trees
won't be a bad thing
ah
okay
how you doing Jake you getting cold
yeah oh what's called your hands
yeah let me see your glass
okay go
we're gonna stick him in Daddy's pocket
to get them warmed up we got some backup
gloves
they are mittens one of your gloves dry
in my pocket when those feels better
then we can switch your gloves back if
you want
thank you
yeah
hey Jacob are you feeling a little cold
you want me to make a little bed for you
yeah okay
we're gonna take off your snow shoes
I've taken my boys camping in some
pretty gnarly conditions and one thing
I've learned never skimp on the kids
sleeping bag because if all else fails
you can always put them in their
sleeping bag
Hey Jake you feeling better
you like your sleeping bag yeah
your feet nice and toasty
all right
like that you ready for some hot dogs
yeah
all right
you're doing a good job with that Jake
you like your hot dog
yes
that's hard to beat a hot dog over a
campfire
you're nice and toasty in your sleeping
bag you want me to get rid of the smoke
okay
I got Jacob fed and warm now I need to
go ahead and process all this wood
one thing I wanted to change about this
fort after my last camp out was I want
to make this platform a little wider
oh
foreign
nice little pile of Timber there
Jakey a little hungry
you know what this is
cookie dough that's what the cookies
look like before you put them in the
oven
[Music]
you like that
oh
laughs
it was
dad what do you think Jake is that
pretty cozy in there
it all up
like
how are we gonna cook
harder
whoa
I've been working like a dog from
sunrise to sunset but unfortunately
that's not a very long time here in
Alaska gotta bust out my lamps a little
bit ready too
oh
I'll tell you these ice fishing sleds
make really good beds for little boys
you put them on a couple logs so they're
up off the ice just put a little foam
mat in the bottom of this thing
now that'll make a cozy little bed
didn't I
oh
you probably need a pillow huh
you want a little headlamp
[Music]
it is now first off they they are scared
of people because people kill wolves
don't you worry
slippers little camping booties to keep
your feet warm you can wear these in
your sleeping bag
yeah see no cold toes I think we should
build a fire don't you
oh wow this shelter just jumped like 20
degrees it is so warm in here but I
gotta keep this fire mellow I don't want
to melt my tarp
well me and Jake are sitting here around
the fire and we're having a conversation
about wolves what do you think about
wolves Jake
you worried about any wolves coming and
getting us did Daddy tell you you're
safe yeah do you believe Daddy
no
the wolves are scared of people will
stay far away especially if you have a
campfire the biggest danger around here
is Moose but just give them enough space
and they'll leave you alone oh that fire
was roaring it was getting to be a bit
much in this shelter so I went ahead and
moved it outside and took some of the
coals and put them right here I'm gonna
go ahead and start cooking some dinner
all right as usual I got a little
something special prepared for dinner
we're gonna have some Philly cheesesteak
sandwiches this is gonna be good
oh
all right we're gonna get Jacob some
food hey Jacob
Jacob buddy
[Music]
oh we we lost you there bud you
how about a big sandwich
yeah that sounds good what do you think
of that
does that look good
I like this you like this Jake
yeah it is hitting the spot
I think I might need to have another one
of those
all right I got something a little
special for dessert here
oh look at that it's got strawberries
raspberries blackberries blueberries
cream
look at this
we got pie for you you want me to spoon
it into your mouth just because I love
you so much and you're so tired
where you like you like dad's booting
pie into your mouth
oh
yeah we don't we don't feed you pie in
bed at home do we is that good yeah
there's no point in leaving leftovers
right
oh that was good
oh
hold on I got you oh that was good
all right guys I'm gonna read Jacob some
stories my dad used to read to me and my
brother when we were out camping this is
a collection of true bear stories from
around Alaska some of these stories are
a little bit intense so I'm gonna try to
pick an age-appropriate one here the
bear then lunged at him and they
embraced in a death struggle the man
using his knife and the bear it's fangs
and Claws well we've had a good time
reading stories and eating whipped cream
but Jacob's falling asleep and I think
it's time for me to get my bed ready too
oh
you know guys I'm pretty proud with the
progress I made on the shelter and I've
got a lot to do tomorrow so we're gonna
have a full day full day tomorrow but I
better get some sleep I'll see you guys
in the morning
well good morning it's about an hour
before Sunrise it's me and Jake are
doing well
it's a little cold in here but uh we're
gonna get a fire started get all nice
and toasty again
yeah
did you get attacked by wolves
all right Jake you want to get some
breakfast
we've got little uh raspberry strudels
and chocolate croissants
because we can
there you go
watch my fingers
I also got some chicken and apple uh
breakfast sausages here we're gonna cook
those up I also got a couple eggs here
we're gonna cook those by the fire stick
goes
right there
what
there we go
well listen I got a bit of building to
do today so I'm gonna go ahead and clean
this stuff up and uh then we're gonna
get to work
foreign
sounds
like the jokes while fat jokes
thank you
foreign
all right let's test it out
[Applause]
now I just need to do a little trim up I
need to make these edges nice and clean
make these logs all the same length
all right
well not too shabby that is a sharp
looking shelter right there yeah I'm
proud of that yeah when you pull the
tarp over the top that thing will get
sealed up really good I'm pretty happy
with the progress we've made today
unfortunately I'm not going to get a
chance to camp in it tonight
because Jacob do you want to go home and
see Mama
yeah yeah I got a little bit left I want
to do on the shelter so I think I'll
save that for my next campout
there you go you good yeah you like it
when you ride out in your sleeping bag
oh
oh there's tons of bunny tracks here Jay
that's where the bunnies have eaten the
bark off the tree that's what they eat
in the wintertime
I can see it we're almost there
all right we made it and looks like some
animals have been visiting this is a
moose track from only a day ago so many
rabbit tracks here let's see if they
went inside yeah there was a bunny went
inside our Fort we had house guests
you know that's pretty hard to do with
snowshoes on there Jake
there we go now go try that ladder yeah
now you're climbing it like a champ why
don't you use the shovel clean off the
snow there
oh
okay
[Applause]
things
[Music]
how you doing are you getting cold Jacob
do you want to get in your sleeping bag
yeah
get some Caribou hides down
there we go
these snowy boots off
get yourself all warmed up get down deep
in that sleeping bag
you want me to get your blankie
okay
there you go ah Jacob's such a trooper
he's been following me around in his
snowshoes for the last two hours but his
fingers are all cold so I threw him in a
sleeping bag gave him some toys in his
blankie he's good to go if you're gonna
take kids out in this weather have a
good sleeping bag a good sleeping bag
can fix a lot of problems
foreign
thank you
all right well the shelter's looking
pretty good I just need some final
touches I really need a chair in there
foreign
thank you
all right now that we got that done I
think we need to get some firewood
chopped up
Sun's starting to set time to get out
our lamps
oh now they got my lights on I think I
need to get a little organized here this
is a bit of a mess
all right
there we go
oh this Fire's just barely started it's
already warming up this shelter just
concentrates that heat so well
there we go now we're cooking with gas
why is this warm
yeah
you like the trail mix bud
yeah you're probably pretty hungry huh I
got a little boy who told me he's hungry
so we're gonna go ahead and get a hot
dog going
oh no
that's a good looking hot dog
the white-bellied Jacob hides in his
burrow and eats his prey
you like your hot dog
all right it's time to start cooking
some dinner and I've got this big cube
of butter here with rosemary basil and
garlic in there and we're gonna just sit
this by the fire and let it get all
melty and mixed together
well I got a sweet potato here and I've
split it long ways and put cinnamon
butter inside and wrapped it in tin foil
we're gonna throw it on the coals and
let this thing slow cook until it's nice
and soft
you getting too hot Jake
there we go
here's your slippers
and all these little Camp booties are
nice all right
are you hungry yeah I'll get you some
crab legs well the sweet potato is
almost done so I think it's time to
start cooking the main course
king crab legs look at these things
check out this is just one king crab leg
it's over two feet long look how thick
that is too so much meat on these things
they're so delicious now you think about
crab legs they're always pre-cooked so
all you got to do is just heat them up
and eat them I take my pot holder
ah
look at this massive joint
that is a solid piece of meat right
there dip that in the rosemary garlic
butter
hmm there's so much meat on these crabs
that one knuckle was like a whole
lobster tail
look at this
oh
yeah look at that sweet potato oh
oh that sweet potato is good
got a piece of cornbread for you too
oh okay
these are on the outside with crabs take
a little bit of this meat
okay
a little butter on there king crab sweet
potato and Cornbread you ready do I hold
it yeah yeah you can hold it
[Music]
oh there we go look at that plate of
food oh that's so good
hmm
that rosemary butter is so good
oh I just inhaled that well guys I got a
belly full of food and I am exhausted so
I'm gonna go ahead and get my bed ready
and get into my sleeping bag but uh it's
way too hot in here I've got to go put
this fire down otherwise I'm gonna roast
tonight
all right
oh my socks are kind of sweaty so I'm
gonna take my socks off and stick them
in the bottom of my bags to dry I want
to put on these slippers keep my feet
warm
all right guys it's late it's time for
bed I'll see you guys in the morning
all the sun's up but I am slow getting
up and at them it's nice and toasty in
my bag oh this is the hardest part of
winter camping
oh I'm so brave
when you first start the fire it just
fills the thing with smoke once the Fire
gets hot though it clears the Smoke Out
there we go it'll warm my boots up a lot
of ice on the inside of this tarp snowed
just a little bit last night there's a
lot of condensation and ice on this tarp
how are we doing all these are all nice
and toasty
oh my socks are nice and warm and dry
well since I'm up and about I'm gonna go
ahead and put my sleeping bag away don't
want it falling in the fire or smelling
like smoke melting sleeping bags has
been a problem lately
foreign
things straightened up in here a little
bit I think it's time to start making
some breakfast
hey good morning Jacob good morning
Daddy you hungry
not right now
Jake you want chocolate croissant I've
got hot chocolate to dip it in uh
let me test it out make sure it's good
um
you like that
all right guys for breakfast we're
having steel cut oatmeal
all right you got a lump of butter and
some brown sugar
there you go you're gonna have the rest
bud
foreign
all right
if I've said it once I've said it a
million times steel cut oatmeal is so
much better than instant oatmeal
um
fills you up properly too
Hey Jake you like the oatmeal
yeah it will oatmeal is an excellent
source of fiber
ah feels nice to have a belly full of
warm food well now that we got breakfast
out of the way I think I need to clean
up a little bit lace is getting messy
okay
all right buddy
gets you
here get in there
Hey Jake you good yeah
foreign
Jacob loaded up somewhere in there you
cozy
[Music]
yeah I wish somebody would pull me in a
sled while I was snuggled in a sleeping
bag that'd be pretty nice
well that's Bear poo right there they're
starting to wake up
so many rabbit poops down there
well today is the day we're going to put
a roof on this shelter and seal it up
[Applause]
foreign
to get a little hungry I think I might
make some lunch
I got some beautiful white bratwurst for
lunch
I love these white brats
foreign
thank you
there you go that looks pretty tight
it's not going to be waterproof but
it'll keep a light drizzle off me and
definitely keep the snow out
thank you
foreign
but I think we got it buttoned up pretty
good
oh I gotta tell you what it's nice up
here so much of that fires heat is
coming up on this platform
toasty warm
I think it's time to make some dinner
I got a little potato there
foreign
this is a Tomahawk Steak and it is a
gorgeous one
um
oh that is a good steak
oh my goodness this is so much food but
the good thing about winter camping The
food doesn't go bad
I'll just uh put that in the snow and
it'll be good for tomorrow
a little salt and butter on a baked
potato not bad at all
it's been one heck of a meal
all right for dessert I've got Ling hee
movie flavored gummy snacks from Hawaii
anything covered in Ling hee movie
Powder is amazing
if you've never had lingi movie Powder
it's uh really hard to describe but you
should go to Hawaii and try it out
that was an amazing meal
but I've got a belly full of delicious
food a warm fire and a cozy shelter so
it's not a bad day
shelter on fire
and y'all better go deal with that
[Music]
catching your shelter on fire is a major
issue all of this wood right here is dry
and warm and if a fire starts it spreads
pretty quick now if you're awake and
paying attention you can put it out
pretty quick but if I was to sleep up
here when that happened I could be
engulfed in flames before I realized
what was going on and this stuff up here
is really dangerous if this stuff
catches on fire I am not going to be
able to put it out in time when I'm
sleeping in these shelters I'll often
Let the Fire go out or I'll keep it
really small and make sure it is far
away from the walls and in a shelter
like this where it's a little bit hard
to get in and out of uh I got to be
extra careful so I'm probably not going
to sleep with the fire on
it's not that cold tonight I don't need
it but in the meantime I'm just gonna
make sure the fire is a little bit
further away from the walls
well guys it's getting dark so I'm gonna
go ahead and make sure I've got enough
firewood for tonight and tomorrow
morning nothing worse than getting up in
the cold and then having to go out and
gather firewood
foreign
exhausted but it's not quite my bedtime
so I'm going to turn on an audiobook I'm
going to Shell some peanuts and I will
see you guys in the morning
oh it's so cozy in my sleeping bag but I
have to use the bathroom so bad
I think I better get out get the fire
started
oh that fire warms this place up so
quickly it's nice
all right I think it's time to get some
breakfast made
foreign
breakfast
we got some smoked pork chow bacon
homemade crumpets that had made a few
days ago Fried Tomato egg
not bad at all
butter and crumpets is hard to beat if
you never had them they're kind of like
thick pancakes really similar recipe to
pancakes
oh that was good well I think it's time
to start straightening up
well guys I'm heading home but this is
not the end of the video first I want to
go get my son and my wife and bring him
over and show them the shelter but also
I need to take the shelter down so
that's something else I'm gonna do and
I'm going to show you too
foreign
let me get the Caribou hides out and you
guys can hang out on the bed while I get
some lunch made
all right should I get a fire start get
all right let's do it here mama let me
hand you the lunch there's some gummy
snacks in there
thank you oh that's for you
yeah you don't get to do this very often
do you
guys like eating gummy snacks in the
fort here good we got some hot dog
sticks here
okay
my first all right yeah you like your
extra long hot dog stick I do
this there you go
you like that is that a good lunch
so mama what do you think is this
shelter warm yeah I'm really cozy I love
the hide I'm sitting on it's soft yeah
no this is pretty cozy I'm fine
I like how the heat comes up underneath
your bottom and warms your bottom up
yeah it is nice especially
yeah all right
it's time to tear the shelter down
oh we gotta pull this all apart make
sure there's no paracord no trash
all right let's get to it all right
foreign
well there we go it's all taken down and
all that Woods ready to be chopped up
into firewood well babe did you enjoy it
is oh you're good you ready all right
let's go
well listen this was fun I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this video if you want
to see more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]